vamos a intentar entender la idea de lo
que es la divergencia y así como le hice
con el vídeo de los gradientes ahora les
mostraré la mecánica que de hecho es muy
sencilla y luego intentaré darles la
intuición ya que tengan la intuición al
principio aparecerá no sé poco intuitivo
quizás pero ya que lo entiendas dirás ah
claro eso es así que veamos qué es la
divergencia imagina primero que tienes
un campo vectorial e imagina que este
campo vectorial puede ser la
visualización de cualquier cosa no sé
este a lo mejor la velocidad de las
partículas de un fluido pues de
cualquier punto en dos dimensiones
correcto así que va a ser un campo
vectorial de dos dimensiones es decir es
una función de xy y entonces la
velocidad en cualquier punto que es un
campo vectorial digamos que no se voy a
inventar algo digamos que es x cuadrada
x cuadrada porque
y donde i es el vector unitario en la
dirección del eje x o también el vector
canónico
el primer vector canónico y ahora le
sumamos nos este 3 y 3 y en la dirección
del eje del ayer justamente que es
nuestro vector j el vector unitario en
la dirección inyectó también es le
conocen como como el vector canónico así
que cuál es la divergencia de este campo
vectorial se puede escribir de varias
maneras la manera correcta de escribir
es la divergencia del campo b aunque
también hay otras reglas nemotécnicas
por ejemplo otra es recordar la
operación de divergencia con el
triangulito al revés como el del
gradiente pero no es el gradiente sino
que vamos a hacer una connotación usando
el producto punto de este con nuestro
campo vectorial b si te quedas de la
discusión de los gradientes dijimos que
el gradiente usando una especie de abuso
de notación pues en realidad
el triangulito para abajo es como el
operador en donde aplicamos la derivada
parcial respecto de x
en la primera dirección de x no en
dirección del vector canónico y más la
parcial respecto de y en la dirección
del vector j
y bueno si tuviéramos más variables por
ejemplo z pues haríamos la parcial
respecto de esas variables pero en fin
vamos a quedarnos con dos dimensiones x
entonces que resultaría de todo esto si
realizamos el producto punto de todo
esto que es el triangulito con nuestro
campo vectorial b entonces qué resultado
obtenemos bueno obtenemos la derivada
parcial de x de la primera entrada es
decir del del campo escalar que
multiplica al vector y ok utilizando
esta regla nemotécnica más la parcial
del campo escalar que multiplica al
vector jota que es 3 verdad entonces si
si escribimos todo esto en base de los
productos puntos y demás entonces
tendremos la parcial de x
respecto a la primera función que es x
cuadrada porque y ahora tomamos la
parcial respecto de y de la segunda
función que es 3 y los sumamos verdad
entonces la parcial respecto de y de 3 y
ahora tendríamos que evaluar qué es esto
estas operaciones que estamos realizando
cual es la derivada parcial de x
cuadrada por y pues bueno y es una
constante para fines de derivar respecto
de x por lo que basta derivar x cuadrada
que es 12 x 2x porque más la derivada
parcial de 3 y respecto de y pues
simplemente es 3 verdad entonces esta
derivada simplemente es 3 y concluimos
que la divergencia del campo es 2 x + 3
ahora esto realmente lo podremos ver
como una función de equis y entonces
vamos a utilizar otra anotación aquí la
divergencia debe en realidad es una
función que depende de xy de ya así que
vamos a hacerlo explícitamente entonces
en cada punto xy tenemos un número real
que está dado por la expresión de esta
divergencia así que pienso que
encontrarán que el cálculo de la
divergencia no es muy complicado sólo se
trata de la derivada parcial de la
componente en la dirección x respecto de
x ya eso le agrega la derivada respecto
de y de la componente en la dirección y
y si tuviéramos más componentes pues la
hacemos lo mismo verdad entonces vamos a
hacer un ejemplo más y luego
trabajaremos con la intuición déjenme
hacer una nueva pantalla entonces si
decimos que ahora el campo veces no se
coseno de coseno de y por iu
pues fíjense que es interesante verdad
que la primera dirección depende de la
segunda que es algo interesante bueno no
se deja lo mejor y le sumamos a la xy
por el vector unitario en la dirección
ya que es j entonces esto es es bastante
sencillo verdad si tienes claro que es
una constante y que no a la hora de
derivar porque la de la divergencia del
campo vectorial b es la derivada de la
primera componente respecto de equis
pero como ésta sólo depende de la
variable y pues al derivar respecto de x
esto simplemente se hace 0 correcto
entonces tendremos como primer sumando 0
y ahora cuál es la derivada de a la
equis y respecto de y bueno pues primero
usamos la regla de la cadena entonces la
derivada de x respecto de ella es x y
luego la derivada de ea lo que sea pues
es a lo que sea que es en este caso a la
x entonces esto es la divergencia bueno
vamos a ignorar el primer semana así que
tenemos que la divergencia es x a la x
y algo que hay que dejar claro es que
cuando tomamos el gradiente en realidad
teníamos una superficie dada por la
gráfica de la función de un campo
escalar y entonces con el gradiente
dábamos un campo vectorial en pocas
palabras teníamos un campo escalar y
encontrábamos un campo vectorial cuando
tomamos la divergencia es la dirección
opuesta comenzamos en el campo vectorial
y bueno que es un campo vectorial pues
que en cada punto x yo le asignó un
vector
si quieres graficar lo en el plano xy
pues tendrás un un montón de vectores
hitos en el plano verdad entonces cuando
tomamos la divergencia en cualquier
punto xy tenemos un campo vectorial del
cual ahora le asignamos un número
escalar en cualquier punto del campo
verdad muy bien entonces vamos a
entender un poco de la intuición de que
realmente la divergencia de un campo
vectorial así que permítanme hacerlo en
una dimensión primero o también podemos
digamos en dos dimensiones en donde uno
va a ser constante
déjenme borrarlo hacer un poco de
espacio ok
no quise hacer ese punto pero bueno
digamos que la velocidad de este fluido
de las partículas de este están dados
por el campo vectorial ve y digamos que
es igual a 5 o equis y más no sé 0 i
no perdón lleno lo que quise decir es
cero jota verdad jota es el vector
unitario en la dirección y entonces
realmente no hay componente y ahora no
necesito una computadora para dibujar
esto creo que puedo arreglármelas yo
mismo entonces si este es el eje y y
este es mi eje x
déjenme ver si entonces cuando x es
igual a no sé voy a poner solo algunos
puntitos los que sean fáciles de
calcular cuando x vale 1 entonces cuál
es la magnitud de este vector pues sería
5 verdad entonces aunque mejor déjenme
cambiar este número porque lo voy a
hacer muy difícil de esa forma entonces
voy a poner mejor un medio entonces
cuando x es 1 la magnitud de mi vector
es un medio solo en la componente
horizontal porque no tiene componente y
entonces podría decir que solo es un
medio de xy verdad entonces solo voy a
elegir los números fáciles por ejemplo
cuando x vale 2
esto es un medio de 2 verdad así que
tenemos que la magnitud es 1 que es un
poquito más grande que el anterior
entonces recordemos que si tengo una
partícula aquí en este punto la
velocidad es en la dirección x y va a
ser de digamos un metro por segundo a la
derecha
si tengo una partícula en uno pues su
velocidad será de un medio de metro
entonces digamos ahora qué pasa con x
igual a 3 pues entonces cuál es mi
velocidad hacia la derecha
bueno pues déjenme hacerlo en un color
diferente para no confundirnos sólo sé
que es hacia la derecha y es un poco más
grande de hecho vale tres medios verdad
y bueno creo que ya tienes la idea
general de que nos movemos en x no
cambia realmente si nos movemos en
puntos hacia arriba verdad así que para
cualquier y la magnitud del vector no
cambia en lo absoluto en lo absoluto ni
siquiera en la dirección sólo depende de
x entonces por ejemplo aquí sería aún
más larga y si dibujamos el vector
todavía más a la derecha se vuelve más
largo y creo que ya entiendes
completamente que cuanto más vayamos a
la derecha las partículas tienen una
velocidad mucho más grande hacia el lado
derecho
me acabo de dar cuenta que me quedo sin
tiempo nos vemos en el próximo vídeo